do you ever see yourself retiring from
rapping I mean as long as the passion
and the loves there like we're talking
earlier I'm sure you're just gonna you
know just keep keep it going because why
not I'm a writer so I don't I don't just
rat like you know like I've wrote
platinum and gold records for several
artists right like I'm saying I think
that's one thing that is always you know
kept me around the basket I'm I got that
pen yeah I can you know I write for
several artists you know knowingly and
those that you like oh I didn't know you
were okay I didn't know you were okay so
um so I love this music and like I say
my Idols aren't just rappers like my
Idols are the Quincy Joneses and you
know the Miles Davis and people that uh
have contributed to music in ways that
um have surpassed just
the rapper mentality like you know what
I mean uh and so I'll always stay around
it I love it yeah I love and then you
know
my hip-hop Dad too short it's like 58
years old
still on tour Mount Westmore
still like grossing 15 20 million a year
from rat at 57 58 years old still coming
with records still being sought after
what's your favorite too short album
getting it getting it's the one but you
know what's crazy I feel like life is
too short was like I think that was like
way yeah well that was like but like
cuss words I just remember learning cuss
words by heart as a kid because it was
like one of the few rap albums my dad
had short dog like I mean like I said
that's my hip-hop dad that's the dude
who you know I call Pops who has taken
me all around the world with him who has
shown me in his most horrific
way of teaching
you just like someone just told me uh
well never mind I don't know I'm
probably not someone's gonna be playing
too short in a movie or a show yeah
Simba oh I didn't know no it's probably
it's public okay I didn't know that it's
public he looks just like him dead on
him it's [__] crazy dead on him he
got the tooth and everything the coat
the hat to the back he so he called me
he called me was like big bro can you
put me on the phone with short man I
just want to show him this little thing
so I facetimed when we all he was like
sure was like oh that's crazy crazy so
and then that right there like that
alone man is just crazy I mean like you
know short is um
short of somebody who
they'll never give him his credit right
like unfortunately it's going to take
for him to ascend after this long and
for people to really be like damn he was
on life after death but he was on volume
two any major album I mean Too Short
like when I was a kid I thought too
short was the biggest rapper in the
world to me like as a little kid I was
like
short is the only artist and not to cut
you off I apologize nah short is the
only artist that has a song with biggie
pot Jay-Z Pimp C
yeah yeah it's like a hit anybody you
name he had his Atlanta run like anybody
you name short has records with the
first time on their album the first time
I ever heard uh Little John was that let
my nuts go right he shine Little John he
signed Little John at 17 and then was so
player he let him go for nothing
like when the major labels wanted to get
little John he John was like man can I
get out this contract and he let him go
he was like go ahead like I'm not do
your thing do your thing and that's why
to this day they have the greatest
relationship and friendship like John
them there just got him The Residency
short big shout outs to short just got a
residency in Vegas
one of them clubs like this is short man
like shortest like I brag and I talk
about him more than he does for himself
like I'm his voice I'm his I'm his come
on like I'm saying and it's just because
I I don't like the way that the industry
tries to normal normalize what he has
done for hip-hop right like how many
people that you know that you can say
was famous
as a rapper in 1982
it's crazy
like bro that's 40 Years bro 41 years
where he was a known rapper famous
really like him and iced tea in terms of
this side yeah like really just them too
come on bro like yeah like you see ice
get a star love Uncle ice that's cute
you sure needs one why not yeah for sure
like one has who has just tell me who
has done more than Too Short in Hip Hop
for the past 40 years right yeah that's
crazy 40 like four and we're not just
talking about like four 40 years I'm
talking about this dude got songs with
Lady Gaga like he's like this is short
yeah like this is short walking up into
the Playboy Mansion I was a kid he walks
up Hugh Hefner walks up to him and was
like what's up Todd I'm like bro you
have knows you by your name this is
crazy
this is crazy to me bro like nobody's
bigger than too short in my eyes man and
like I say man like even right now and I
just text him and he's like
till this day
pops what you doing man I'm in the
studio man I'm in the lab man
like he's like I'm stealing it like
every he's still there like this is
crazy bro so